[Musik]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
wird den bediensteten über soldatinnen
und soldaten
wir dürfen sie zum ersten video blog zu
unserem thema der geologie des proma wir
uns ganz herzlich begrüßen wir die
türkische dienst möchte sie laufend über
die aktuellen befragungen zu den
einstellungen verhaltensweisen der
österreich und österreich und vermögen
wir haben dazu daten von gallup markt
für sie aufbereitet
welche regelmäßig ca taucht
österreicherinnen und österreicher zu
verschiedenen themen wohnen diese krise
befragen
diese daten wollen ihnen jetzt um den
laufenden bock beitrag in kompakter form
aufbereiten
auf die frage zur pedro lichkeit zur
subjektiven bedrohlichkeit des
kommunismus darf ich ihre aufmerksamkeit
auf den ersten ball quäntchen der
kalenderwoche ziehen anfang februar in
dieser woche haben 22 prozent der
befragten das virus als bedrohlich
eingeschätzt und im gleichen zeitraum
sehen sie dass lediglich fünf prozent
hier was wir uns als sehr bedrohlich
wahrgenommen haben
sie sehen wir verlaufen wie die
kalenderwoche 11 12 13 zur geländer
woche 14 am 31 märz hier seht ihr das
bild das immer sechs prozent der
befragten das sind ja alles gar nicht
bedrohlich empfunden haben und sie sehen
auch deutlich in dieser befragung woche
das bereits 23% dass wir als sehr
bedrohlich eingeschätzt habe
die maßnahmen werden von der bevölkerung
dementsprechend wieder nach und
zustimmung als gerechtfertigt eingestuft
das heißt in den wetten befragungen märz
gaben bereits über man sagen dass die
macht der regierung für gerechtfertigt
empfinden so wert hat sich seit anfang
februar deutlich gesteigert und ist nun
beim servo niveau stabil geblieben
auf die frage hin ob sich die schüler
persönlich an diese auffällig maßnahmen
erhalten
ziehen sie dass 97 prozent der befragten
das heißt eigentlich fast die gesamte
bevölkerung sich hier sicher auf den und
maßnahmen halten
die den österreicherinnen und
österreichern mit den maßnahmen zu
beginnen
im märz kamen ein großer über 90 prozent
der befragten gut bis sehr gut mit den
maßnahmen zu recht auch jetzt ist noch
der großteil der bevölkerung der meinung
mit den machern im unterricht zu kommen
allerdings ist er an wenn jeder personen
die sehr gut mit den namen zurecht
kommen leicht sinkend wenn die
aufmerksamkeit der befragten auch das
handeln berichtet wird so sehen sie dass
mehr als die hälfte 55 prozent
das handeln für angemessen die welt wird
sie sehen dass bei 15 prozent die
warnung ist dass die situation zu ernst
genommen
sie sehen auch dass bei 29 prozent der
anderen personen die wagen mit dass in
situation nicht ernst genug
pastor wahrnimmt sondern das was findet
die maßnahmen im öffentlichen raum nicht
einhalten
dies betrifft etwa das social distanz
ging das heißt das nicht einhalten des
abstandes zu anderen personen aber auch
handlungen wie das umarmen oder
händeschütteln mit der anderen bewohnern
werden die personen befragt es ist
derzeit fühlen so gibt über die hälfte
an entspannen mit profit derzeitige
situation zu sein
jedoch gaben 14 prozent der befragten an
sich er bisher sozial hinzufügen und
soziale unterstützung zu benötigen
das heißt jeder siebte der befragten
personen gibt abend mehr zu zahlen von
tag zu benötigen oder unterstützung von
außen
meine
das war unser erster videoblog wir
möchten uns weltpresse ganz herzlich
bedanken dann wieder sehr freuen wenn
sie das nächste mal wieder dabei
naschen
[Musik]